the trial of the attackers charged with
killing a young American in Greece is
all set to begin tomorrow
only on CBS this morning the parents of
bukhari Henderson are speaking out a mob
chased down there 22 year old son down
the street last year while he was on
vacation in the summer and beat him to
death on the Greek island of Zakynthos
there are nine defendants in this case
mostly of Serbian descent six could face
a life sentence if convicted a voluntary
manslaughter three others face lesser
charges CBS this morning Saturday coast
Michelle Miller spoke with Henderson's
parents as they prepare to face her
son's alleged killers Michelle this is
such a sad story I'm so glad you're
doing it good morning everyone
the brutal beating of Bakari Henderson
was captured on video and prosecutors
are said to be confident they have a
strong case but CBS News has learned an
important witness likely won't be in
court to testify
we spoke with makaras parents about how
they're feeling as they set out to
attend the trial Phil and Jill Henderson
kept a positive outlook this week as
they began their journey for justice
what does justice look like for you and
your family justice for me and my family
will be that the guys who did this would
definitely get them the max in us for
what they've done to this family
surveillance video shows what the
defendants allegedly did to their son
Bakari in Greece chasing him down the
street knocking him off his feet and
beating him to death his face was
bruised and swelling to the point where
we put sunglasses on him when we buried
him a Serbian woman told investigators
it started when she posed for a selfie
with Bukhari she claimed a man nearby
said quote there are a lot of Serbs in
the bar why are you talking to a black
guy security footage shows a man struck
Bakari in the face
moments later Bakari hit back and others
got involved as the scuffle moved
outside video from another camera which
has not been seen publicly until now
shows Bukhari backing up kicking one of
his attackers and walking away before
another man began throwing barstools at
him
to a court filing a witness claim
Bukhari was verbally provoking the
attackers shouting come here come what
does that tell you does it tell you
anything does it does it even matter and
my mind words don't kill people so so
yeah I don't
that's not justification to kill anyone
the court has called Phil Henderson to
testify about his son who only weeks
before the attack had graduated from the
University of Arizona with a degree in
business finance in entrepreneurship
Bakari was in Greece last year on a
photo shoot for a clothing line he was
launching three friends who were with
him have also been summoned to testify
but multiple sources tell CBS News one
of those friends is unlikely to show up
we know from speaking to the family that
he's been having a hard time with them
yeah I think he's fearful so fearful in
what way
probably just based on you know what he
saw happened to Bakari and to know that
you have to testify against those same
individuals I think it's causing him
some fear neither the friend nor his
family responded to messages from CBS
News
we need that witness the Hendersons
lawyer earl ward says the video gives
prosecutors a strong case but first-hand
accounts would add invaluable context
he's an eyewitness to the vicious
assault on Bakari he saw what happened
to this young man and so he's necessary
I see you guys have your passports ready
to go yeah we do Jill and bill Henderson
have waited 14 months for this trip but
even now they say it still feels unreal
do you imagine looking at those men's
faces while you sit in court I haven't
gone there yet truthfully so how about
you Phil have you gone there yes and
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be very
hard all of the defendants have been
denied or have denied the charges their
fate will be determined by a panel of
three judges and for citizens in the
Greek city of pitous two of the nine
defendants were released before trial
and are believed to have returned to
Serbia CBS News has learned they won't
be coming back for trial and will
instead be tried in absentia the
Hendersons believe that race may have
played a role in their son's death well
I have enormous sympathy for them having
to go to this trial you know but on the
other I'm just glad there is a trial yes
so long they were worried in a foreign
country whether there would be a trial
for their son's death and when you think
he's 22 years old he was six foot five
and Phil I talked to the family as you
know to last year he died in less than
30 seconds 22 years of life you were
beaten to death on camera and you die
and listen I don't care how many times
yeah I don't care how many times you
look at those pictures images they're so
upsetting yeah the video is is
condemning yes yeah you see that crowd
and yes a whoa yeah all right Michelle
Miller Thanks